I was what mystical after a beauty Will
Smith his back people yeah
welcome to Collider nightmare Collider
name-o david frankel hey he's directed
[ __ ] that I've seen Keira Knightley okay
ones that are in this to really that's
it it's a combination yeah
two wonderfully talented British chicks
who do you think is hotter compare leave
it in the comments below and Edward
Norton - hey oh I got me Enya
oh let Michael cut is this movie I
haven't heard of this you just keep
getting me more and more excited the
more you say stuff or there's so many
feelings feet or is the window so many
famous beer a great so many famous
people it's like that it's like one of
those Gary Marshall movies rest in peace
yeah and those movies were great those
were fence Ezzor the best to connect
love Tommy dad these three things
connects every single human being on
earth we long for love we wish we had
more time we fear that
did you lose a child Howard
Howard as a creative charismatic I used
to love life right now he hates it I try
to talk to him
I tried to reach him and he's not there
I miss him he writes letters who are
they - Howard doesn't write letters to
people he writes two things time love
death kids write letters as Han of
course it doesn't want to crazy no this
is therapeutic oh did you write the
letter - I wrote a letter to death nice
to meet you charmed I'm sure
no personal response but you are I don't
want this any time I'm a gift and you're
wasting it you don't think I'm crazy
oops not having conversations I love you
I saw you in her eyes when she called me
daddy and you betrayed me
the reason for everything if you can
accept that then maybe you get to live
again
there's so much more at stake here than
you even understands
and they'll appear
you've been given a gift it's profound
connection to everything
I promise you it's there
that is real beauty what else is david
frankel directed uh he did seven gone
girl The Devil Wears Prada Marley me
alright so yes guys that's a pretty
worthwhile boos I think it looks like a
really delightful drama uh yeah it looks
like a good time of course is people are
gonna be thinking of films like Scrooge
the stories of cruise you know like past
present future I love that idea of
talking with love time and death because
yeah man those are like I'm I consider
myself a guy who is fascinated with
things like that and certain
philosophical discussions such as that
it's a cool idea to be like if you
that's an opportunity that would if you
plug yourself into it yeah I could
really use that I would be very curious
to think about that and I like stories
when they talk with like the physical
embodiment of like an emotion or
something like you know some type of
thing that's not considered to be a
thing you could talk to you but then
they make it a human type or form yeah
it's like an abstract fantasy in in a
slight way it's it's you know it's a
little more abstract than your
run-of-the-mill in a sort of Oscar movie
you really amped up all the emotions and
something like stranger than fiction
yeah where it's like you know it's kind
of a fantastical drama but it's about
like very human you know dealing with
depression and confronting different you
know aspects of life I feel like with
love time and death I mean those three
categories are a very reoccurring topic
in life I was just listening to a little
bit of the audio of the power today that
book it's all about the law of love and
the power of love and how everything
comes down to love or the lack of love I
believe that I believe like that's
essentially what everything is and how
we view things and what we do is love or
the lack of that's the stuff that drives
the momentum
yeah yeah that's what gives us that we
get what we want based off our that
concept and use everything to get back
to the stuff that we love and time is a
is a reoccurring topic and most people
who I meet in terms of time management
and feeling like we don't have enough
time to do what we want to do or we need
more time and it brings me back to
that I heard one of my favorite personal
development speakers say rich people
have 24 hours in the day poor people
have 24 hours in a day the difference of
those two do is what they do it though
in that time yeah I've also heard that
same speakers say life is the struggle
to keep death at a respectable distance
yeah I do think that when it comes to
relating to the masses yeah this is it
well every time in death huge
metaphysical tenets that you can point
to for like there are other concerns but
you know like love death and timer like
3 very broad life thing yeah and I feel
like they're gonna explore them in an
interesting fashion yeah I like how they
got really well-known actors to play
these characters I like the whole group
friends thing of these like big actors
playing normal dudes who are yes served
about one another you know like I mean
sure you get this big cast together you
I'm sure if you first hear that caster
for first thoughts boy like you're gonna
see something
ripping drama everyone's crying and
everything really emotive it's yelling
intense but it's it doesn't look like
it's gonna be portrayed that way and I
like that because that's another form of
just of acting that's another form of
just being a human being because there's
plenty of human beings who would have a
conversation like that like sitting
around the table talking about your
friend and what they're going through I
thought that was a nice moment actually
to see Edward Norton just plain like
nice likeable friend in this movie yeah
it always a very specific kind of
character but everyone seems is very
relatable and you know different
ethnicities and stuff which is cool yeah
I'm curious how that's cuz it cuz it
looks certainly interesting and I like
the fantasy aspects and stuff like this
I haven't seen a lot of David's wrinkles
other movies I did see The Devil Wears
Prada like I was surprised by how much I
liked that he does a lot of really
heartfelt films yeah yeah and so what
I'm curious now to see is like how well
they stick the landing of this because I
know he's done some like you know okay a
sentimental dramas but this looks like
it could be a really cool really event
I'm going human drama yeah like I hope
this is great
I'm a little afraid it could end up
being a little like oh you tried but
it's a little ham-fisted and I feel like
it could be great I feel like with just
with this subject alone and the town
they're going for I feel like there's
gonna be people undoubtedly who are
going to say that even if the majority
don't think that there's gonna be at
least a minority that will say yeah yeah
it's all cheesy but but like you know
it's like if Spike Jonze made this movie
I wouldn't necessarily be working yeah
cuz it is like fantastical strange but
you know there's certain people who you
can count on to deliver like more than
just a swelling you know heart movie I
feel like it's it's a little bit more
grounded because I feel like a spike
jonze did this what do you want a war
what I'd ask oh yeah but the same words
yeah yeah yeah the kind of fantasy is
not it is something I associate more
with Spike Jonze again I like Will Smith
in these like depressing kind of roles
he don't like not just I am Legend but
even that movie seven pounds see I
thought about seven pounds then I
thought about this and I was like okay
it almost seems like they're going okay
Will Smith can really act and we can
really do like a great even drama with
him but we're also gonna like tone it
down a little bit maybe add a little
humor that's what's cool it's cuz it's a
nice mix of Will Smith's charm and
charisma but you could tell he's not
like forcing that in there that this is
a he just seems like he's playing a
regular dude I like seeing that I just
like seeing these like character actors
playing regular people regular folks the
different tones they showed you know
they showed stuff that looked like it
would be more intense and kind of you
know sad or stuff that's a little more
funny and a little more fantastic yeah
each one of those none of them seem too
huge you know it's like it does seem
like a human level of things and it's
when you see it you're caught by it cuz
you know we're usually used to seeing a
more heightened stuff in movies yeah
yeah so this is cool for me because I
was like oh yeah they just sort of seem
like they're trying to capture life you
know like a slice of life one thing I
thought that was a little interesting
was when they said like okay Helen
Mirren first shows up as death and in
time like you yeah I thought it's a kind
of an interesting approach to just see
them as real dudes
instead of like Helen Mirren showing up
all dressed in the black dress yeah
doing something that's like wow she
really represents death but if this was
fight sounds like that would be that's
that's what I mean it's like instead of
doing like crazy visual effect
representation of these people were
stylistic cinematic angles around these
guys they just look like regular people
appearing yeah why yeah like slightly
stylized but yeah mostly just like
normal and kind of different you might
expect people yeah yeah that's the thing
that's most Ricky's I love the premise
of this cuz like I would love to be able
to do that and it just gets you thinking
about that like what would I say like I
like a movie like this that can take you
on a little thought journey where it's
like well what I say to tell him or
death or or love yeah let's say they do
Keira Knightley or this is this is an
interesting premise to to get all these
actors together to act out a fictional
tale but without going like crazy
Hollywood on it so still allowing these
guys to just give performances so I feel
like if there's any cheesiness it's
gonna come down to the writing and
directing more than it will be the
acting I don't know what this one was
gonna be like but here's I can tell you
it's about love time to death and it
takes place in Christmas and like
Christmas times from the producer
spotlight which a man like spotlight
seemed like it did get any molestation
of a man I did that's why he's so
depression and then by the end of the
movie we find out and then all never
like oh yeah we can't help you do like
wait wait wait this is what Deadshot was
doing before Batman captured him oh my
god again I got the joke I made the joke
I got the joke oh oh you did it I
thought you were never goes like
something's missing right now and I
can't figure out and I realized I
haven't delivered an original joke yet
oh [ __ ]
that's what the original earth i five
comet that on the trailer before someone
else does yeah first cool beans well
yeah that was sent to me on twitter by
someone saying I should have remembered
who said it to me
but yeah I want to see the same movie
but with Arnall instead yeah I don't
know what to say
I'd love to palm dye my big blue viewed
on Lookout my clock in my mind well that
seemed like a new person to this channel
subscribe if you're already subscribed
right John is a Twitter handle Instagram
reasons to Jerry's social media manager
of Facebook and the real rejects as well
so tune in to those FTL's
shout out how to hear and nightly you
didn't return for pirates pirates but
kind of a bummer a buzzer makes me go
what happened where the [ __ ] is he run
nightly Helen Mirren and Helen Mirren I
love you want to documentary now it's
just funny it's very very pleased when
the hottest old lady is beautiful yeah
like when people magazine decides to
take paparazzi photos of like people at
the beach like silicon beach regular
people minding their own business if we
could snap a photo with a movie to judge
their body type on a day where they
haven't prepared yeah if Helen Mirren
ever spoke to me I think I would just
like I would shed a single joyous tear
and then melt like yeah I'll just kind
of ooze into into it like a sunbeam and
go away I fart know at fart not in front
of Helen Mirren although should probably
be cool about it yeah